they look like prisons although china
has always claimed these are vocational
training centers
but beijing's denials that what's
happening in these camps amounts to
widespread and serious human rights
violations have suffered a setback with
the publication of a damning u.n report
it states the treatment in xinjiang of
the uyghur people
may amount to crimes against humanity
the high commissioner's report did talk
about a wide range of issues ranging
from ill treatment uh internment uh
sexual and and uh physical violence and
so on and uh she does conclude that you
know these allegations uh are credible
the u.s government claims china's
repression of the uyghurs is genocide
with evidence of force sterilizations
and torture in concentration camps
these pictures posted anonymously on
youtube appear to show hundreds of
prisoners being led away
their heads are shaved and they're
handcuffed
activists say more than a million have
been detained in the last few years
these are just some of their faces
sky news has also gathered testimony
from people who've been imprisoned
this man shows scars consistent with
torture
the un report stopped short of using the
word genocide
there's also been criticism as to why
its publication was delayed
we knew the report was ready september
last year and having promised a the
report will be published would be
published and we waited for so long and
you cannot imagine
how hard it is how difficult it is for
us to fight for just the report to be
published
the report does though add weight to
well-documented evidence alleging
beijing is carrying out a
state-sponsored program of torture and
persecution
but china's foreign ministry has
rejected the findings
foreign
china has always maintained what's
happening in xinjiang
is a security measure to prevent
violence from militant uyghur
separatists
but beijing's critics say with the un
now accepting horrific crimes are being
committed in this region
the international community must act
alex rossi sky news